-Welcome back.
as I said, it's Friday.
This is when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
-Really?
-I check my inbox,
I return some emails,
and, of course, I send out
thank-you notes.
-Oh.
-And I was running a bit behind.
[ Cheering and applause ]
I was just wondering, if I can,
can I write out
some thank-you notes right now,
in front of you guys?
[ Cheering and applause ]
I appreciate it.
I'll be very quick.
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
-[ Playing tender tune ]
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, fake vampire teeth,
for being Invisalign
for the undead.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ooh!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, "Dune,"
or, as I like to call you,
dry "Aquaman."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I call it that?
-That's what you call it.
-My man Jason Momoa.
-Yeah.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you, Houston Astros
and Atlanta Braves,
[ Cheering and applause ]
for somehow both having mascots
that look like
bootleg Shrek costumes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What are these things?
-There was a discount.
-Go, Houston!
-Sure.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, World Series trophy,
for looking more like an award
that's given
to Lipstick of the Year.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Patagonia releasing
their own bottles
of natural wine,
for bringing a whole new meaning
to the term white wine.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ As Jerry Lewis ]
As I got it.
-[ As Jerry Lewis ] I got it.
-I think I understood that.
-That was pretty funny.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
couples' Halloween costumes,
for all ways making it clear
which person picked the costume.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
trick-or-treating chaperones,
for basically looking like
Secret Service agents
who protect Spider-Man and Elsa.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheering ]
-Get up there.
-They're going --
They're going to the door.
They're ringing
the doorbell now.
[ Laughter ]
-The Applejack has landed.
♪♪
-Thank you, pumpkins,
for being the only thing you can
just put on the ground and go,
"Alright, I decorated."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It works.
-These gourds
have been here all year.
-Yeah, they're beautiful.
-Thank you.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Halloween wigs,
for looking great in the package
and making me look like
Spooky Boris Johnson
when I put it on.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This is Aquaman?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you,
spider web decorations,
for being cotton balls going
through a goth phase.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it everybody.
Those are our thank-you notes.